every character from The Walking Dead
has a fun following and Carol is no
exception
watching her arc take her from domestic
abuse and zombie apocalypse survivors a
gun-toting badass has been an incredible
journey driven by some powerful
performances from Melissa McBride she's
proven she can play everything from
battered wife to trembling survivor to
someone capable of doing whatever it
takes and we mean whatever just look at
the flowers ouch there's no doubt
mcbride has become part of the heart and
soul of the show but you've seen her
before too even if she looks so
different that you might not have
actually realized that born in Kentucky
McBride headed to Atlanta in the 1980s
to start what's been a wildly random
career throughout the 1990s she appeared
in the slew of commercials are seen to
have been lost to the mists of time but
footage of her first major acting credit
thankfully remains she appeared in a
1993 episode of Matlock playing the
fidgety darling Kellogg in a bizarre
episode called
Matt loves bad bad bad dream the story
starts of Matlock meeting some friends
and a jazz nightclub and restaurant and
he's introduced to Darlene who's craving
a cigarette but trying to quit the rest
of the episode is literally right off of
Matlock's nightmare and when his dreams
transport him back to a Prohibition
themed restaurant she shows up at a
1930s era cigarette girl her long curly
hair was the height of fashion in the
1990s for sure but it also makes her
look completely different in an epic
twist it's completely possible to
imagine season one Carole watching that
exact show while doing ads ironing
MacBride still sported her 90s curls and
her next role a small part in the
long-running southern cop drama in the
heat of the night her role in the 1994
two-part episodes give me your life is
admittedly brief McBride plays a
reporter determined to get the story
during an investigation into a shady
Church in Mississippi while she's
playing a pretty stereotypical plucky
news reporter there are still some hints
of the McBride would later come to know
and love it only lasted a single season
in 1995 before being cancelled but the
supernatural horror mystery show
American Gothic had some big names
attached
including executive producer Sam Raimi
and a cast that included eventual a
listers Evan Rachel Wood Sarah Paulson
Lucas black and Gary Cole McBride
appeared in the episode dead for the
world as a sheriff's one-time girlfriend
who disappeared under mysterious
circumstances appearing in a flashback
scene Holly Gallagher is an archetype
familiar to McBride fans the
eager-to-please woman who thrives in a
caretaker role she said herself that had
some things he has in common with
Carroll telling AMC I've gotten myself
into some difficult situations because I
couldn't say no actually I've got myself
into some difficult places because I
thought I could fix somebody after
appearing in a handful of made-for-tv
movies of names like a season in
purgatory anyplace but home and close to
danger McBride landed in a two-part
episode of Walker Texas Ranger alongside
living internet meme Chuck Norris Chuck
Norris doesn't turn butter he roundhouse
kicks the cows and the butter comes
straight out again in a nurturing role
McBride played Rachel Wood a pediatric
doctor tasked was caring for a young
patient played by Haley Joel Osment
who's been removed from a house during a
drug bust walker Tony Abbott yep it was
hot episode in the cult hit 1990 series
Dawson's Creek Dawson and his friends
head to a bar in an attempt to distract
him from his broken heart when he spots
McBride's Nina from across the bar he
knows he's found the one
Nina Chatsworth Dawson for a bit and
invites him back to her place to hang
out and watch movies which is a nineties
version of Netflix and chill he passes
but they still share a kiss making
McBride the focus of all kinds of
fangirl jealousy long before anyone ever
started one thing Carol and Daryl to be
a thing
when McBride was approached to audition
for the 2007 adaptation of Stephen
King's the mist she was initially
reluctant but she went along and
eventually landed a gig that would lead
her to a most iconic role she not only
got the role described only in the
credits as a woman with kids at home but
she made such an impression on producer
Frank Darabont's so when it came time to
start casting for the walking dead a few
years later he gave her a call it's
absolutely not surprising even though
she's only in a single early scene and
in the final moments of the movie the
ending to the mist has one that sticks
with those that see it she doesn't say
anything
and she doesn't have to it's no wonder
Darabont captain number even with
Carol's increasing importance on the
walking dead McBride is still found time
to do occasional work outside the show
in 2014 the reconstruction of William
zero debuted at the Fantasia Film
Festival in Montreal described as a
suburban mad scientist ale McBride plays
one of the scientist colleagues in a
mind-bending drama that deals of some
pretty heavy material the moral of the
story suggests as no shortcut around
grief and that the only way to get
through it is to deal with it head-on a
message Carol would certainly approve
off thanks for watching click the loop
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know your love to
[Music]